welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and
they gotta let me sleep sometime this is
my third breakdown in two weeks but a
seemingly endless supply of Mario
trailers that are being released but
they are great trailers and this one had
tons of Easter eggs packed into it I
guarantee you haven't seen or heard at
least one of these yet now it does share
a bit of toe Town footage from the last
breakdown I did so watch that one as
well to get all the hidden details so
let's go we opened to a triumphant
Fanfare playing over a sweeping view of
toad town and while I said in my last
breakdown that I was dying to see the
background more clearly the majority of
the details actually in the foreground
we'll dive more in depth into some of
the buildings in a sec but you can see
the roofs of the food court and the fish
shop that we see better later and what I
thought was a frying pan and satellite
in the blurry footage last time turned
out to be a hanging Hammer sign which is
more than likely signifying a tool shop
which there are a few of around town you
can also see them here and here and this
side is why I believe they're more
likely tool shops than weapon shops and
much like the Starbucks of our world
there's a coffee shop on every corner in
toad Town look here are four of them
which might explain where all of the
toads energy comes from also we're gonna
play a game throughout this video called
what's that where if something looks
like it should be a reference but I
don't know what it is I'm gonna go what
is that and you leave it in the comments
if you know what it is that being said
this balcony and that green toad house
back there what's that all right now
we're entering detail city as Toad and
Mario make their way through the streets
I only have limited time in these videos
but I will spend two seconds pointing
out how seductively this toad is
stroking this deck of coins or what
Mario picks up a coin that this green
toad dropped in this Hustler of a red
toad claims it and I really like how
they're demonstrating Mario's kindness
and willingness to help throughout this
tour he observes how different
everything is but never looks down on
the Toads or bashes their way of life
and that's a great demonstration of his
character but back to the details we see
the store that sells fish which could be
seen more clearly in the promotional
poster that was originally released a
telephone booth station and more of the
symbol blocks for their pipe system and
I think I'm getting closer to figuring
out the system I believe the top blocks
represent the sectors the green leaf
sector the blue mushroom sector and the
yellow fire flower sector and then the
symbol on the Block represents which
Landmark you'll end up by like the
fountain or the castle or Tower and the
number of blocks represent how many
pipes it could lead to like here we see
two blocks and the toad goes in when
they both change to Towers later we see
a toad go in when there's two arrows and
the next Toad go in when it's two crowns
so maybe pipes that have one block only
go to one place and pipe set up two
blocks go to two potential places also
what's interesting is that in the last
footage we got the weight sign was an X
and then this one it's a hand with a
seven on it maybe indicating that you
have to wait a certain number of seconds
depending on how long the pipe is I'm
starting to feel like Charlie day here
I'm on camera a lot so I have to see my
face a lot so you'd think I'd have to
put a lot of effort into my skincare
routine but I don't because I use
geology
geology is a 15-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast birdie Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
and they've recently expanded to offer
products for pretty much whatever you
need all you've got to do is take a
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology figures out your routine for you
if you need Hair Care use geology's
co-wash a specially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big
leather or harsh ingredients of typical
shampoo and for the rest of your shower
routine you can use their body washes
which are free of harsh ingredients
smell great and are refillable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stresses with vitamin C
plus e for Rolex serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant then quite honestly really
smells great right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely insane offer if you
use code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing some
stocking instead either way geology has
you covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all of your favorite
geology products to get started just
click the link in the description take a
30 second diagnostic quiz and their team
of dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door but back to
the trailer there's a toad that takes a
picture of the yellow camera that very
slightly resembles the N64 camera which
we also see another toad has a little
later and another game of what's that
there's a house with a room with glowing
purple lights that I can't quite place
from a game but it looks a little like
the background panel of the quiz show in
Paper Mario definitely gives off a party
Vibe though and then above it there's a
sign that again what's yeah a blue shell
to Nuki Leaf a beeper what there's also
a crazy cap store from Mario Odyssey and
a store that looks like it sells the
veggies from Super Mario Bros 2 to me
but it could also be fruit next to it we
see a shop with the same pow Barrel from
the poster as well as the newly cheeked
up plumber approaches what looks to be a
sort of food court or shopping center
judging from the sign with food and
drinks on it in the stores where you can
buy Desserts and Drinks there are toads
being served drinks and eating desserts
now I'm a little astonished that with
all the food and drinks in this trailer
aside from the fruit none of the rest
seems to come from the games desserts
are clearly a big part of this world as
you see many toads both in the
background and foreground eating sweets
throughout and I'm guessing this is
important because there are many levels
in the Mario games that feature sweets
but you're gonna tell me I looked
through all the 79 types of drinks in
the Mario games just for them to use
random grain and white cups that's
messed up man and what are these bright
blue cupcakes why do they show up twice
why is this toad wearing a sombrero I
don't know what to say about that anyway
at the same time we see the poster of a
band with Toadette in it toad greets a
purple toad named chantrell which is the
name of the singer of Club 64 and Paper
Mario who's also purple Mar walks by a
cheap chief that gives him a death glare
perhaps alluding to the enemies
naturally being drawn to attack Mario
and then we get to the Big Kahuna the
antique shop let's just go from the
foreground to the background and I'm
gonna say Bros for all these just to
save time we've got access from Super
Mario Bros and an open sign that looks
like the title screen the dragon coin
from Super Mario World Treasure Chest
from Super Mario Bros 3 keys from a few
of the Mario games a pixelated version
of a super Bell a boomerang flower the
toad is holding an NES cartridge that
the shopkeeper says he has to blow into
referencing how it was a popular Theory
back in the day that if a game cartridge
wasn't working you should blow into it
to get it to work again then a chest
full of coins a hammer from Super Mario
Bros 3 and a sign with the coin cost of
a Tanooki Suit a mushroom and a super
Leaf moving on to the middle section of
the store there's a poster of the end of
World War III of Super Mario Bros what I
believe is a school box from Super Mario
World exclamation blocks something I
can't quite make out but what might be a
mannequin hand holding a warp whistle
from Super Mario Bros 3 points the magic
ones from Super Mario Bros 3 and there's
something on that bottom shelf but when
I adjust the levels they look like
eggplants which can't be right but I'm
not gonna say what's that because it's
funnier to me if I believe they're
eggplants there's more stickers on the
Shelf in the middle magic potions from
Super Mario Bros 2 a magic box from
Super Mario Bros 3 and an egg in a case
the poster shows more clearly that it's
a Yoshi egg and you can kind of see the
spots in the windows reflection in the
trailer but I think it's probably just a
Yoshi egg lamp since it's glowing so
brightly you can barely see the spots
and it has a golden face then in the
back of the store we have a poster of
Princess Peach from her letters in Super
Mario Bros 3 along with p-wings from the
same game he balloons from Super Mario
World he switches and clouds from Super
Mario Bros 3. Spring's first appearing
in Super Mario Bros the Lost Levels but
looking a lot like the Super Mario World
ones and anchors from Super Mario Bros
3. before we move away from the antique
shop many fans are speculating that the
shopkeeper is voiced by Charles martinet
we know that Martinez is going to be
doing one or potentially multiple vocal
cameos for this movie and some think
that this might be him many people
believe some of the Toads also sound
like they may be voiced by Samantha
Kelly Who's the present voice of toad in
the games along with Princess Peach
Toadette and Baby Peach finally moving
on from the antique shop while Toad and
Mario get onto the moving platform in
the background we can see a fountain
that's probably in the process of being
built judging by the fully functioning
pipe Fountain later in the trailer we
can also see that many of the crates
surrounding them are fruit crates and
while we mentioned fruits from Super
Mario Sunshine making an appearance last
time the grapes on this crate and
watermelons on a cart later looks like
they're also going to be pulling from
Yoshi's Story one cute little detail in
this shot is that toad holds his arms
over the barrier to wait for Mario like
he's holding an elevator and when they
head up we can see a bit of the
warehouse-esque Interior that the
Builder toads have access to there are a
few openings scattered throughout the
trailer so I'm hoping we get a better
look at what's inside of this whole
production very Disney tunnels then we
get a couple of maps in the next shot
one of them looks like it's a map of the
Mushroom Kingdom and a Super Mario World
world map Style and what I think is
really interesting about this map is
that there are six distinctive icons it
uses a red fire flower a green Yoshi egg
a yellow mushroom a greenish fire flower
a one up and a blue fire flower hour and
yes I know ice flowers exist but this
flower over here looks like a distinctly
different color so they might just be
color-coded fire flowers remember the
yellow one from earlier now each of
these icons is next to a pipe except for
the red fire flower on the left which
doesn't seem to have a pipe for some
reason since there are six lands it's
possible that each of these pipes leads
to a different land this yellow mushroom
is by the pipe that leads to Peach's
castle it's safe to say that the
Mushroom Kingdom would be the yellow
mushroom the Yoshi egg assumingly goes
to Yoshi's Island and if it is an ice
flower the blue flower might lead to the
ice kingdom besides that it's anyone's
guess if I had to venture a guess I'd
say the red fire flower might go to the
desert and the one up might go to Donkey
Kong Country and the greenish fire
flower might go to the dark lands but
just a guess looking at the other map
above them it's drawn more in the style
of Super Mario Brothers 3 as you can
tell by the coin checkpoints one of the
icons is a mushroom which perfectly
matches the mushroom next to the sign
which leads me to believe that this is a
stop on the way but the palm tree and
pyramid later down the map lead me to
believe this mode of transportation
might lead through the desert land and
that castle is not peaches Castle but a
generic castle that in the game belongs
to a king of that land if theories about
the desert land being sarasaland are
correct and there's a castle we might
just be getting Princess Daisy after all
aside from the maps though another
cheeky detail is that Mario runs off the
platform the same distinctive way he
runs in Mario 3D World a couple shots
later we see some toads looking through
binoculars one of them being almost the
same color as the binoculars in Mario
Odyssey and then after flying through
the pipe system Mario finally lands at
the castle Gates where we get a new
perspective on Peach's castle which like
the other trailers continues to have
cute little details like the sculptures
that look like golden mushrooms and the
star detailing on the gate so those are
all the visual Easter eggs but you would
be amazed at how many Easter eggs are
hidden within the audio let's start with
the sheer number of songs they fit in
from the Mario games we open to the
first three notes from the fossil false
theme from Super Mario Odyssey in a
raised heat then we touch the toad house
theme from Super Mario Brothers 3 before
a sting that sounds like the Spade bonus
song from the same game place then this
melts into the Overworld theme from
Super Mario Brothers during this when
the cheap cheap mean mugs Mario an
extremely subtle line of the underwater
theme from Super Mario Brothers plays
which blew my mind
about halfway through we hear the bomb
Battlefield theme from Super Mario 64.
and shortly after a tiny bit of the
underground theme from Super Mario
Brothers we hear the Yoshi theme from
Super Mario World and when Mario comes
out of the pipe at the end a little
moment of the Super Mario Bros level
clear Fanfare plays
oh
[Applause]
followed by a nod at the Super Mario
Galaxy 2 theme to close the trailer and
let's talk sound effects when the first
toad hits the Coin Block it makes the
coin sound effect from Super Mario World
but when the second toad hits it it
sounds a bit more like the Super Mario
Galaxy coin sound effects when Mario's
passing the antique store we hear the
faint sound of a one up and what sounds
like one of Mario's explanations from
Super Mario 64. along with the sound of
him getting hurt from the same game when
he's traveling through the pipes finally
when he comes out of the pipe at the end
there's a little hook that's originally
from new Super Mario Brothers DS so that
was a wild amount all packed into one
little clip and until the next one you
can follow me on Twitter at it'sanna
vanston and follow And subscribe to new
rockstars at new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love I'm
gonna go try to squeeze in a power nap
before I start writing the next one
[Music]
thank you
[Music]